bonjour merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation l'utilisation du vaccin
astrazeneca est donc provisoirement
suspendue en france après qu'une dizaine
de pays dont l'allemagne en pris la même
décision c'était important que la france
fasse de même
oui c'était important pour pouvoir
rassurer la population de décider de
suspendre ce produit et puis de
réétudier et de donner les informations
scientifiques parce que là il y avait un
peu le sentiment que ben pour les plus
anciens d'entre nous on était confronté
au nuage de tchernobyl
arrêté à la frontière alors que quantité
de d'autres pays décidé de suspendre
alors je tiens quand même à rassurer les
gens qui ont déjà été vaccinées par
astrazeneca
il ya un tiers de la population du
royaume uni qui a été vaccinée des
millions d'autres dans le reste du monde
et ça c'est pas si mal passé que que ça
néanmoins il était important de pouvoir
rassurer parce que ce vaccin eh bien il
a une moindre efficacité que les autres
qui ont été autorisés en france il ya eu
la communication sur la vaccination des
plus âgés il ya le problème des effets
secondaires au bénin dans les 48 heures
qui suivent
l'injection donc ça commence à faire
beaucoup pour un seul vaccin est donc
c'était normal de mettre les choses à
plat et de pouvoir sereinement étudier
et rassurer la population
alors on parle de la mort d'une
soignante en norvège d'un enseignant en
italie tous deux après avoir été
vaccinés on évoque aussi la possible
formation de caillots sanguins formé
chez certains patients vaccinés vous
pensez vraiment qu'il peut y avoir un
lien entre ce vaccin et ses
complications
ça va être un scientifique de le dire
c'est pour ça qu'il était important de
de suspendre le temps d'étudier après
encore une fois il ya des millions de
personnes qui ont été vaccinées sans
souci néanmoins on voit bien que c'est
un vaccin qui suscite un certain nombre
de de crainte ou de freins il est
important de tenir compte de ça bon la
france a quand même gardé
c'est un peu dommage de décider ça au
dernier moment très rare oui oui
clairement c'est une erreur nous nous
demandions depuis plusieurs jours de
faire une suspension le temps de pouvoir
étudier et rassurer la population
lundi robin à 16h30 je suspens jusqu'à
demain après midi
c'est à l'image de notre gouvernement
jean castex le chef du gouvernement
hier encore affirmé qu'il fallait avoir
confiance à au vaccin astrazeneca
qu'est ce qui a changé la donne selon
vous est le fait que de nombreux autres
pays bien prenne cette décision c'est ce
qui a encouragé emmanuel macron allait
suivre la décision de l'allemagne donc
le suma prompt à faire un copier coller
est un peu dommage pour la sixième
puissance mondiale que on n'anticipe pas
les choses pour faire valoir le principe
de précaution de manière normale
plutôt que d'attendre ce que le grand
frère et des cités alors pendant
l'exercice de vos fonctions vous est-ce
que vous avez noté une certaine défiance
des patients vers ce vaccin ainsi que
des mauvaises réactions
il y a les réactions telles que les
thromboses absolument pas par contre on
est confronté quand même ou souci d du
syndrome grippal pour les jeunes
vacciner dans les 48 heures qui suit
l'injection qui est un vrai problème
pour
la vaccination des soignants parce que
lorsque vous avez 20 % de l'effectif qui
doit s'arrêter
quarante-huit heures suite à un syndrome
grippal
ça fait autant de soin est néanmoins
dans les services alors qu'on ne vend
sous-effectif partout c'est ce qui a
paralysé un certain nombre d'hôpitaux de
de l'ouest de la france avant que l'
agence de sécurité du médicament en
france des 6e de faire en sorte qu on ne
vaccine pas tout vi en même temps
justement pour tenir compte de ces 48
heures des effets secondaires sur 20%
des soignants alors on sait que le
personnel soignant la vaccination se
faire en ce moment est-ce que vous avez
été vaccinées vous moi j'ai eu le cogic
donc j'ai un délai pour être vacciné et
puis ensuite il y aura qu'une seule
injection et non pas le sait les
dernières recommandations de la haute
autorité de santé il ya soixante dix
mille hospitalier et puis 55 1000e
soignants délais des ehpad est dédiée le
qui ne peuvent pas se faire vacciner
parce qu'il ya ce délai de six mois
alors on l'a dit un emmanuel macron
attend l'avis de l'agencé européenne des
médicaments pour et bien se prononcer
pour décider si la vaccination reprendra
au prat ou pas avec astrazeneca vous
pensez vous que l'autorité européenne
peut retirer son autorisation
son homologation pour ce vaccin
astrazeneca
c'est aux scientifiques de le dire
maintenant encore une fois un tiers de
la population de la grande bretagne a
été activé et vous avez des millions
d'autres personnes qui ont été vaccinées
en travers le monde maintenant il ya
quand même un problème d'efficacité de
ce vaccin qui est beau et efficace que
les autres c'est pour ça qu'un certain
nombre de soignants ne serait pas avoir
astrazeneca par rapport à l'efficacité
en particulier sur le variant sud
africain comprenez bien que les
soignants de moselle par exemple un
département où le variant sud africain
est à plus de 50 % lorsqu'on leur
propose de les vacciner avec astrazeneca
qui a été arrêté en afrique du sud parce
qu'il n'est efficace qu'à 22 % sur le
variant suite africain ça pose problème
est donc clairement astrazeneca n'est
pas adapté aux soignants qui sont
surexposés en terme de fréquence
d'exposition et de charge virale et
passion dont il s'occupe thierry
amouroux merci d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes
porte parole du syndicat national des
professionnels infirmiers merci beaucoup